Jedes Jahr pustet die Schifffahrt weltweit
eine Megatonne CO2 in die Luft. Das sind
fast drei Prozent der weltweiten CO2-Emissionen
und damit mehr als ganz Deutschland! Und Schiffe
verschmutzen die Luft. Manche Städte
verbannen Kreuzfahrtschiffe deshalb
sogar schon aus ihren Häfen! Außerdem
kommt es immer wieder zu Ölkatastrophen.
Aber wir brauchen die Schifffahrt. 90 Prozent
aller Güter weltweit werden auf dem Wasser
transportiert. Dein Laptop oder Handy, auf dem
du dieses Video schaust, dein Shirt, dein Kaffee
heute morgen – all das wurde wahrscheinlich
irgendwann einmal per Schiff befördert.
Es muss sich also etwas ändern. Dafür gibt
es auch eine Menge Vorschläge. Schiffe mit
High-Tech-Segeln, E-Fuels, Luftbläschen, die unter
das Schiff gepustet werden oder Haifischlack. Aber
welche dieser Ideen helfen uns tatsächlich?
Genau das klären wir heute bei Doktor Whatson.
Obwohl die Emissionen von Schiffen ein
Riesen-Problem sind, werden sie bisher kaum
reguliert – nicht global im Pariser Klimaabkommen
und auch nicht durch die EU. Das liegt daran,
dass die internationalen Gewässer und die dort
verursachten Emissionen keinem einzelnen Staat
zugeordnet werden können und sich dadurch niemand
so richtig verantwortlich fühlt. Trotzdem gibt es
mittlerweile Klimaziele für die Branche; von der
“International Maritime Organization” der UN.
Dieses Jahr wurden die so angepasst, dass die
Schifffahrt bis 2050 klimaneutral werden soll.
Damit das klappt, müssen wir komplett
neu denken. Schiffe müssen bald
emissionsfrei angetrieben werden. Im Gespräch
ist hier vieles: batterieelektrisch, Wasserstoff,
E-Fuels, LNG, und sogar Wind. Also, schauen
wir uns mal die wichtigsten Kandidaten an:
In den letzten Jahren hat LNG eine steile Karriere
hingelegt. Das ist flüssiges Erdgas oder liquid
natural gas. Dabei spart es eigentlich kaum
CO2-Emissionen! LNG wird bei minus 162 Grad
verflüssigt gelagert. Es verbrennt sauberer als
Diesel und Öl, daher entstehen deutlich weniger
Feinstaub und Stickoxide, aber trotzdem ist es
ein fossiler Rohstoff. Darum werden lokal nur
etwa 20 Prozent CO2 eingespart. Und das ist noch
ziemlich optimistisch. Denn die Herstellung und
Kühlung sorgen für zusätzliche Emissionen.
Und: Erdgas besteht vorrangig aus Methan,
von dem je nach Motor etwas entweichen kann.
Weil Methan etwa 25-mal so schädlich ist wie CO2,
können die Klimaschäden bei der Verwendung von
Methan sogar größer sein als bei Schweröl. LNG
sollte damit aus Klimagründen höchstens
als Brückentechnologie gesehen werden.
Nächster Kandidat: Strom. Wie sieht es mit der
Größe und dem Gewicht der Akkus aus? In China ist
im Juli ein komplett elektrisches Frachtschiff mit
Platz für immerhin 700 Container in See gestochen.
Zum Vergleich: Das größte Frachtschiff der
Welt kann über 24.000 Container transportieren.
Die Akkus befinden sich – smarterweise – in
austauschbaren Containern, macht ja Sinn. Aber das
Schiff ist “nur” für eine Strecke von etwa 1.000
Kilometern ausgelegt – dann muss getauscht werden.
Das heißt: Batterieelektrisch funktioniert,
aber aktuell nur für kürzere Strecken. Für
eine Atlantiküberquerung brauchen wir noch
andere Lösungen – oder bessere Akkutechnologie.
Auch Wasserstoff ist hauptsächlich für kürzere
und mittlere Strecken sinnvoll. Das liegt daran,
dass die Tanks im Vergleich zu
Schweröl viereinhalb bis acht mal
so groß sein müssten, je nachdem, wie
stark der Wasserstoff komprimiert wurde.
Okay, also was ist mit längeren Strecken? Im
Gespräch dafür sind Methanol und Ammoniak.
Beides kann mittels Strom als E-Fuel hergestellt
werden. Und auch die Energiedichte ist ähnlich.
Ähnlich schlecht, aber immerhin besser als bei
Wasserstoff: Man bräuchte etwa zweieinhalb mal so
viel Ammoniak oder Methanol wie Schweröl, um die
gleiche Strecke zurückzulegen. Um weiterhin alle
Ziele zu erreichen, müsste man also zusätzlich
einen Extra-Tankstopp einrichten oder einen Teil
der Ladung durch mehr Treibstoff ersetzen.
Weil es keinen Kohlenstoff enthält,
gibt es auch keine lokalen CO2-Emissionen bei
der Verbrennung. Bei der Herstellung gilt aber:
Wie bei allen E-Fuels sind sie ökologisch nur dann
sinnvoll, wenn erneuerbarer Strom eingesetzt wird.
In der Handhabung ist Ammoniak aber ziemlich
kompliziert. Es kann ohne weitere Maßnahmen
für Feinstaubbelastung sorgen, ist giftig und
sowieso eine ätzende Angelegenheit. Das bedeutet:
spezielle Treibstofftanks, neue Belüftungssysteme
und besondere Vorsichtsmaßnahmen. Wenn euch zu
grünem Ammoniak ein extra Video interessiert,
dann schreibt uns das gerne mal in die Kommentare.
Das ist bei Methanol deutlich leichter:
Die Feinstaubbelastung ist gering,
und Methanol ist biologisch abbaubar.
Das bedeutet, selbst bei einem Unfall,
wo Treibstoff austritt, besteht kaum
Gefahr für Wasserlebewesen. Und genau
deswegen ist Methanol ein Pferd, auf das
große Reedereien jetzt gerade setzen.
Maersk, die zweitgrößte Reederei der Welt,
hat schon über 100 dieser Methanol-Schiffe
bestellt und rüstet alte Schiffe auf Methanol
um. Allerdings handelt es sich um sogenannte
Dual-Fuel-Ships, die auch mit fossilen
Kraftstoffen betrieben werden können,
je nachdem, was gerade verfügbar
ist. Es kann also durchaus sein,
dass die Dual-Fuel-Schiffe erstmal
nicht mit grünem Methanol, sondern
mit fossilen Treibstoffen betrieben werden.
Dazu konnten wir keine genauen Infos finden.
Das wäre auch nicht unbedingt die Schuld der
Reederei. Denn es gibt für grünes Methanol kaum
Lieferketten und Produktionsstätten. Und
dadurch taucht ein Henne-Ei-Problem auf:
Sich als Reederei für einen und gegen
einen anderen Treibstoff zu entscheiden,
ist ein großes Commitment. Denn Containerschiffe
sind 25 bis 40 Jahre in Betrieb, und Umrüstungen
sind teurer als das Schiff direkt so zu bauen.
Das heißt: Wer jetzt falsch, oder auch einfach nur
“anders” als der Rest der Branche entscheidet,
wird in Zukunft von der Konkurrenz abgehängt.
Im Moment ist die Frage, wohin sich der
Markt bewegt, noch offen. Und das ist ein
Problem. Wenn sich der riesige Markt auf viele
einzelne Treibstoffe aufteilen würde, würde es
kompliziert und teuer werden. Die Entscheidung
weiter aufzuschieben geht aber auch nicht,
weil die Schiffe so lange in Betrieb sind, dass
sie noch jahrzehntelang CO2 und Schadstoffe
emittieren würden. Für Motorenhersteller wie MAN
gibt es so außerdem kaum Planungssicherheit für
die Motorenentwicklung. Ein Experte fordert sogar,
diese Entscheidung nicht dem Markt zu überlassen,
sondern dass die Staaten hier kooperieren und
sich für einen E-Fuels entscheiden.
Okay, cool, aber es gibt noch eine Antriebsart,
die komplett kostenlos ist, nichts wiegt und fast
immer verfügbar ist. Eine, die Menschen
schon ewig nutzen. Wie wäre es mit Wind?
Vielleicht hast du diese Bilder hier schon mal
gesehen. Das sind sogenannte Wingsails. Aber
wie genau funktionieren sie? Normale Segel
funktionieren entweder durch Widerstand oder
durch Auftrieb. Auftrieb sehen wir sonst auch bei
Flugzeugtragflächen: Der Wind streicht auf einer
Seite langsamer vorbei, und dadurch entsteht
ein Überdruck, der das Boot nach vorne drückt.
Was aber nicht so ist wie bei einer Tragfläche:
Das Segel soll den Wind von beiden Seiten nutzen
können. Segeltuch beult sich in beide
Richtungen und kann so eine Art Kammer
erzeugen. Bei den soliden Wingsails geht das
nicht, darum muss das Wingsail symmetrisch
sein. Um trotzdem eine Art Kammer zu erzeugen,
wurde das Segel um einen zweiten Flügel ergänzt.
Wind klingt erstmal sehr nachhaltig, was man
aber vergisst: Solche Wingsails herzustellen
ist ganz schön aufwändig. Eines der
Wingsails vom “Oceanbird”-Schiff soll
während der gesamten Lebensdauer von 25
Jahren etwa 1.300 Tonnen CO2-Emissionen
erzeugen. Der größte Teil entsteht
bei der Produktion des Wingsails,
der Rest zum Beispiel durchs Aus- und
Einklappen der Segel. Nach Berechnungen
von Oceanbird werden diese Emissionen aber
schon nach weniger als einem Jahr eingespart.
Auch Wingsails werden aber nicht die Lösung für
alle Probleme sein: Erstens soll die Oceanbird
langsamer fahren, nur 10 Knoten statt 22, wie für
diesen Schiffstyp üblich. Das bedeutet natürlich:
höhere Kosten für die Crew und weniger
Aufträge pro Jahr. Und insgesamt braucht
man mehr Schiffe, um die gleiche Menge an Waren zu
transportieren.Aber: langsam fahren ist trotzdem
eine super Idee, vor allem abseits vom Segeln.
Beim “Slow Steaming” wird nämlich auch eine Menge
Treibstoff gespart. Ein Containerschiff
spart bis zu 53 Prozent Treibstoff,
wenn es nur 20 Prozent langsamer fährt.
Und das wiederum spart Geld und CO2.
Okay, zurück zum Wind. Der kann auch mit diesen
Segeln genutzt werden. Ja, richtig gehört, das
sind quasi Segel, auch wenn sie nicht so aussehen.
Diese Flettner-Rotoren funktionieren durch den
Magnus-Effekt: Wenn sich ein drehendes Objekt wie
ein Ball oder ein Zylinder durch die Luft bewegt,
wirbelt es die Luft mit der Drehung mit. Die
Luft bewegt sich auf einer Seite schneller,
auf der anderen langsamer. Und schnellere
Luft bedeutet weniger Druck. Ein Sog zieht
das Objekt also im rechten Winkel
zur Luftströmung nach vorne. Bei
den Flettner-Rotoren dreht ein Motor die
Säulen in der entsprechenden Geschwindigkeit,
aber dabei entsteht mit relativ
wenig Einsatz ein großer Vortrieb.
Theoretisch kann ein Schiff ausschließlich mit
diesen Rotoren fahren. Aber realistischer und
vielseitiger ist es, andere Antriebe damit
zu ergänzen. Und wie viel Treibstoff kann
damit genau eingespart werden? Das ist
leider gar nicht so leicht zu sagen und
kommt natürlich auf das Schiff, die Route,
den Wind und die Fahrgeschwindigkeit an.
In dieser Studie wurden Flettner-Rotoren
und solche Kites untersucht. Sie zeigt,
dass drei Flettner-Rotoren über 50
Prozent der Antriebsenergie von so
einem Schiff leisten können. Ein Kite kommt
auf Bestwerte von 32 bis 40 Prozent Einsparung.
[Werbung/Ad]
Was aber auch super wichtig ist,
ist, dass die Materialien sehr leicht
sind. Und wie man das erreichen kann,
das schaue ich mir heute hier an, denn ich
bin heute im 3M Innovation Center in Neuss.
3M hat sich unter anderem darauf spezialisiert,
bewährte Konzepte neu zu denken und Lösungen für
Probleme zu finden, die noch gar
nicht richtig formuliert wurden.
Eine dieser innovativen Lösungen von 3M zielt
zum Beispiel auf die Transportindustrie ab.
Egal ob Schiffe, LKWs oder E-Fahrzeuge:
Gewicht ist immer ein limitierender Faktor!
Um maximal nachhaltig und wirtschaftlich
zu sein, muss ein Fahrzeug daher vor allem
leicht sein. Hier können die sogenannten Glass
Bubbles von 3M einen echten Vorteil bringen.
Diese Glass Bubbles werden als strukturelle
Grundlage von Bauteilen wie beispielsweise
einer Motorhaube verwendet und sind durch ihre
Kugelform wesentlich stabiler als herkömmliche
Füllstoffe. Entscheidend ist aber, dass
durch die geringe Dichte dieser winzigen
Glashohlkugeln eine Gewichtsreduktion von
bis zu 45% möglich ist. Spritzgussteile oder
Faser-Kunststoff-Verbundteile, die häufig in der
Industrie verwendet werden, werden so deutlich
leichter und ermöglichen dadurch, dass E-Autos
beispielsweise eine höhere Reichweite haben.
Falls ihr mehr darüber erfahren wollt, dann
haben wir euch in der Videobeschreibung mit
einem Link zu 3M Glass Bubbles und zu ihrem
deutschsprachigen YouTube-Kanal versorgt.
Aber jetzt geht es erstmal mit innovativen
Ideen rund um das Schiff der Zukunft weiter!
Ok, was, wenn wir richtig verrückt werden?
Bei der sogenannten Luftschmierung werden
zum Beispiel Luftbläschen unters Schiff geblasen.
Das Schiff fährt damit über eine Art Teppich
aus Bläschen, was die Reibung verringert.
Auch, wenn sich das bisher nicht komplett
durchgesetzt hat, verwenden schon einige
der größten Containerschiffe das System.
Außerdem gibt es spezielle Lacke, mit
denen Schiffe behandelt werden können.
Dadurch soll die Oberfläche
der Haut von Haien ähneln,
was besonders hydrodynamisch sein soll.
Allerdings sind die Effizienzsteigerungen
dadurch schlecht belegt, und mittlerweile
ist es ruhig um das Produkt geworden.
Was zusätzlich Treibstoff sparen
könnte: größere Schiffe. Klingt komisch,
ist aber so. Wenige große Schiffe brauchen
weniger Treibstoff als mehrere kleine.
Allerdings wird es irgendwann auch in den
Schleusen und Häfen knapp. Die Kanäle,
auf die der Welthandel angewiesen ist,
wurden zwar schon mehrfach vergrößert,
aber die größten Containerschiffe sind
sogar für den Panamakanal zu groß.
Natürlich ist auch die Schiffsform total
entscheidend. Die low hanging fruits sind
aber in den letzten Jahrzehnten
schon abgefrühstückt worden. Nach
Experteneinschätzungen sind hier nur
noch kleinere Einsparungen zu holen.
Okay, größere Schiffe, langsamere
Schiffe, Rotoren, Wingsails. Und was noch?
Über einen Trend wollen wir noch sprechen:
Digitalisierung und autonome Schifffahrt.
Es gibt immer bessere Computermodelle und
Wetterdaten. Wenn Zonen mit schlechtem
Wetter einfach umfahren werden und
natürliche Strömungen genutzt werden,
kann das den Treibstoffverbrauch senken.
Außerdem kann damit die Wartezeit an
Schleusen oder Häfen verringert werden.
Und das wiederum schafft Kapazitäten,
sodass sogar noch Verkehr von der vollgestopften
Straße aufs Wasser verlegt werden kann. Nice!
Okay, und wie kann autonomes Fahren
der Schifffahrt helfen? Wie überall:
Es herrscht Fachkräftemangel. Mit Slow
Steaming braucht man sogar noch mehr Personal,
das noch länger unterwegs ist. Selbst
wenn Schiffe nicht völlig autonom fahren,
sondern von Land ferngesteuert werden, sorgt das
für attraktive Arbeitsbedingungen in der Branche.
Also, wie sieht das Schiff
der Zukunft aus? Klar ist:
Es wird ein Hybrid aus vielen Technologien,
die wir heute schon kennen und weiterentwickeln
müssen. Von Flettner-Rotoren bis hin
zu autonomen Schiffen – die Zukunft der
Schifffahrt ist vielseitig. Aber das stellt
Reedereien auch vor die Herausforderung,
einen neuen Kurs einzuschlagen. Oder die Segel
neu zu setzen. Schreibt mir euren schlechtesten
Lieblingswortwitz dazu in die Kommentare.
Bis dahin, bleibt neugierig! Euer Cedric.